The cool thing about the way plus works in Python is, there's nothing really
special about it, it's just a short way of calling a magic method. What that
means is when you have an expression, a plus b, what's really going on here is
that you're calling a function and it's the function that you get by looking at
the type of a for the attribute_ add _. Which is function that takes two
inputs and, a and b are those inputs. So the only thing that's magic about plus
is that there's a special syntax that makes it easier to use. When you start
defining your own types, which we'll get to pretty soon, well you define a plus
operator for your own types. So what that means is that you can actually make
plus work for your own types by defining an add method. And, we're getting a
little ahead of ourselves, so we'll get to that later. But that's something to
look forward to that you'll be able to define your own types, and give plus
whatever meaning you want, for them.